My name is Jason, CEO of Veewo
We specialize in creating small but fun games
Since we started our company in 2011.
Some of our games have been officially promoted to Google Play
Such as Dark Slash: Hero and Just Get 10
Our latest games have been a good hit
World-wide is a movement game
Called Super Phantom Cat
And thanks to the Google Play Games services
We were able to reach as many Android users as possible
Where the game achieved 870 thousand visits and 120 thousand downloads in a week.
It is an extraordinary achievement that we never imagined before
Make a decision to make it possible to work on Android TV at an early stage.
10% of our users currently play the game on TV.
As game makers, in our youth we were fans of television games, and we are very proud.
I'm "Yup" Veewo product
Let us use demo and quick versions
Success on Google Play.
Since we implemented the pilot,
The number of users rose steadily from 4.1 to 4.6.
Thanks to the game distribution model on groups,
We were able to aggregate valuable comments
Before making any bold updates
We have made our game very stable in quality.
Google Play helps us live up to the promise we made with the best games.
Admob is at the top of our revenue resources
Our profits continue to increase
Thanks to its high viewing rate.
The company's income has increased tenfold over the last four years.
Google Play also allows us to respond to user feedback in comments on games.
This feature has not only helped us reduce our users' loss by only 31%
But gave us an opportunity to establish friendship between us and some players.
Players want to talk to game developers, and we're more sure about it now.
Promotional codes give us a new way to work
Google Play in-app promotions allow us to reward users anytime, anywhere.
We can offer rewards in the form of a unique virtual character design or level with special content.
Google Play makes it easy to connect with players
It helps us improve the game and facilitate its work.
About 70% of our businesses and players now have their primary Android system source
This growth is more confident in our future.
We want to keep our team's future:
Offering great gaming experiences to our players.